on this episode I have my dad join me
ah
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this episode 118 of the askgaryvee show
so as you can see this is a vet this is
my father Sasha a lot of you don't know
my dad I love my dad very very much my
dad is a an immigrant from the former
Soviet Union who I'm very fond of many
of you have crossed over from Wine
Library TV to the askgaryvee show know
this character many of you are about to
have some fun times as you can see we
have a lot of food and wine here we just
taped seven six or seven videos that
will run in Wine Library where my dad is
the founder CEO and owner of Stefan and
ek and D rocker here we played four or
five hours of basketball I'm actually on
family vacation right now I'm supposed
to be option yeah we do it every year
every year I'm supposed to be off the
grid but we decided to tape some wine
videos and I've been missing the show I
know I've been traveling a lot I know I
come back are we getting one in on
Monday I didn't want to sneak one in on
Monday but then again on the West Coast
India unfortunately is not here so Andy
let me get up d-roc you're gonna have to
roll with me here Andy who Andy em you
haven't really been on the show and he
was a big part of our team does all the
paid acquisition a lot of you who
discovered me on Facebook it's because
Andy and I but really Andy have been
very strategic about finding you and
your facebook feed so Andy let's get
into the show the show I tricked you so
have an image yeah why is it made
gallery the famous no Andy did not make
a famous oh I made Andy famous that's
right all right just you made me famous
dad Oh göran let's get into show Andy
Melanie asked
you've led Wine Library in vaynermedia
through insane growth what's your best
advice to those leading grow
in teens you know I think one of the
things that I think about when growing
and and you know Wine Library probably
from 1998 dad until 2004 or five and
that in the kind of that five or six
seven year period we probably went from
what how many employees do you think
when I would dick and Bob even be ten
twelve to like eighty or ninety right
that's what would you saying that five
or significant so but we're always there
yes another uh but war stuff for reason
yeah we were growing we're growing and
the same thing is happening now with a
I'm sure AJ would now say we're over
staffed is we've gone from thirty to
five hundred twenty-five people in the
last three years add up at vaynermedia I
think the big thing for me and it's
interesting it's fun to have my dad here
um the big thing with me that I think is
a little bit different than my dad and
AJ I'm just I'm kind of when you're
going through and saying Ruth I
definitely don't worry about the little
things you've got to move fast there's
gonna be a ton of headaches there's
going to always be issues but I try to
focus on the top-line right when you're
trying to grow quickly you're you're
really growing top-line revenue um a lot
of times you know that may be at the
mercy of gross profit net profit um for
sure there's always issues with
personnel there's always there's always
disagreements and things of that nature
but for me it's not so adding the small
things to me I keep my heads very much
in the cloud I really focus on the
agenda at hand and I I think where most
people struggle is they focus on the
small things they they get caught up in
things that may not matter as much in a
net-net game and I think that that has
been a very major factor in my business
success that I'm able to not get caught
up in the things that I think the far
majority people get caught up in I think
people get emotional about things I
think people don't project financial
outcomes you know are you know both when
I got involved in my dad's business and
with vaynermedia the growth of the
revenue on the high end on the top-line
was very extreme and uh and I think that
that's something that people struggle to
calibrate to me it's not sweating the
small things that yeah great
let's get into the next question
well right yeah you know look um you
know a lot of people now watch the show
the show's gotten very big I don't know
if you know I didn't ask every show it's
very big um so how come the first time
on the show well I mean it's all just
worked out timing you're very busy
you're busy you don't come to New York
when I'm taking the show um yeah you you
have here you have a you have a very
different point of view you have a very
unique point of view on me that the
audience does not have do you listen no
question about not because he's my son
he is a very very special kid no no I'm
almost 40 dad so no you always gonna be
a kid I know wait yes I got it whatever
doctor why don't you tell the audience
when you first realize how special I was
oh I know whatever early stage no tell
them there's only fun for me [ __ ] I
can't get you no no I always give you
the credit we're not ready it's always a
rocket what I'm going to tell you to
face all have one four wheel no no it's
called red drapery right oh you're going
way back it's food no wait I was ten I
was ten what's yours a whole 1985 no no
before it's dog with matter
yeah 1985 I was ten when I do the mini
flea market medium far and e-mini flea
dated but yep we have some cockamamy
include red blue dreamy and my day at
that time I used to take sunday off once
in a while to spend quality time with my
children
that's right which meant we would sleep
listen I used to work 16 hours days 14
hours days sure it's not so easy no but
mom gave you the Draper's right yeah I
sold it and they were stunned
yeah and Grandma yeah and yeah well I
knew that
listen I knew it you my son right when I
get a letter you
supposedly no I did legend you like that
yep
more than a thousand dollars dollars to
start my baseball card business when I
was 14 business with right right yeah
and a couple people said to me you know
you need you're never going to see this
money back 80 back fast
test like was in the months mmm-hmm and
that was hard I was there like 1989 when
I could only go to a show once every
other weekend who start working with us
for Kenwood sharda Negros it was shoddy
well I dad I asked you to move yeah you
can what I sold to get right yeah yeah
yeah yeah what's up all right let's go
anger let's go buzz HR asks I started a
daily vlog series should I focus on
youtube facebook video or both Buzzard
this is interesting we're in a very
interesting time right now with YouTube
and that's the name day that's probably
screaming buzzer uh there's a Marie
interesting time right now um I think
YouTube and Facebook video or both the
two dominant platforms but I think six
or seven months ago D rocket we okay
with a sound I know it's windy we'll
just go with it
um you know I think that uh by the way
I'm so pumped the askgaryvee show
audience is not ready for all this
craziness go I think show AJ show AJ
real quick let's get let's go say hi to
AJ AJ very good hey just got his drone
rockets alright we're almost done we're
doing a podcast carry the episode with
death row fit God yeah Dez your phone
was disconnected to the camera yeah do
you think's because we turn on the ass
before we've sink the - right like man
you're off and put it back on hey we
tried a lot of that by doing the sound
yeah this is black and white right now
AJ what there's gonna be a lot of black
and white this on first thing buzz yeah
III think that facebook video is grossly
underestimated I think YouTube is
obviously the established leader but I
think Facebook's uncredible Andy and I
have been doing enormous amounts of
testing on audiences right now we're
running a ton so many of you watched the
USC video if you haven't watch it here
link it up over my dad's face yeah um
uh and so uh I think that um I think
it's incredibly effective there's
nothing like Facebook targeting and I
think both the answer is both I think
both really matter
um and I can say that you know look I
mean eating our own dog food Andy I
think we're really focusing on Facebook
right now but we kind of have
understanding what YouTube's all about
but the targeting is just incredible on
Facebook's answers both brother focus on
both the to Vaughn John asks what's one
question you get asked all the time you
can't stand and what's one question i I
get asked all the time that I don't that
I can't stand answering um which one is
that then the valdes creepy no right not
you I know you're not a big Pinot guy
all right you're right over anything
that is not a wine show you can finish
it finish it
um I don't know if there's any question
that bothers me that people is so chill
nothing you know really it doesn't take
some personal living you dad
yeah you know what that I'm gonna take
advantage of having you here you know
obviously we're same but we're very
different but you've got a lot of me yes
I know I'm in the batter you know is the
competitive thing yeah you know it's
more yeah but but were you interested in
the fact that I'm so unfazed you get you
listen there's a lot of people watching
telling you you get upset about a lot of
things of course I'm a human I mean I
but yeah but you admit you agree in
business I'm kind of weird right I go
into the squared state where I'm not
she's different
and she's very deep I have to hand it to
him not because he's sitting here and I
real gonna give him company and you know
white guys just so you know I'm fishing
here because I don't get this amusing
advantage of the show yeah yeah but he's
very different here he made a statement
and I can't even repeat the statement
because I don't that to me it's against
my religion he won't do business with
anybody Hitler that would be same you
know it's Robson is the wrong way but
that's true it's been proven fact
and I'm a principal guy not a principal
guy you are
but you put what good for the business
before you my own feelings yeah and I
can't and I'm exactly reverse yeah you
know yeah um I don't know a new problem
that's what was holding me back oh yeah
listen I'm not complaining I did put a
hoodie yes a mr. boots no language no
you know about here I can write a look
at my book would be a better than he is
but that's beside the point
he's making a face you know II can't
because of that that's why I'm making a
face yeah let's play one-on-one show the
basket way to play one-on-one like
settle listen we just had them way
younger son got married and AJ you know
AJ everybody Nelson and you would not
like what a place at the wedding I mean
Gary get my speech I gave a speech my
daughter jumpin became more very
competitive family yeah yeah I'm healthy
very healthy and why we unhealthy but
I'm aware on how it what do you mean
unhealthy well we're aware of the day we
wanted you know even in the business
never left ups you never left upset with
me I know always win within a year we
never left upset in a day we kiss each
other well we love ya
so I don't know what a question but I
think ultimately Andy there's no
question that really bothers me you know
I think that most people I think that
most people know the answers to most of
the questions that they ask me I just
don't think they want to put in the work
and one thing that you know I will I
will say this I think one of the best
days of my life but I'll say this in
front of you this is fun for me one of
the best days of my life my life the
life that I've lived 40 almost 40 years
now was when um was when me I don't you
know 20 it's great as a day of this was
in my life I don't fully remember it but
I do remember several months ago maybe
within the year maybe within 18 months
you kind of telling me like man for as
hard as I work you work real
I would honestly I felt at the time I
would heart working hard someday some
with 14 hours all this [ __ ] this one but
Sun God for his wife I have to say this
not every woman with us true guy
troubles a half a year he should trump
these guys now and these guys yes they
know he's the best
yeah that's why this week server love
her I mean her fact I just discussed was
a mom another day about the your
situation not that the woman would to
you know listen it's intense
yeah we're going for it but I'm a dream
like I had when I came to this contract
never going to forget and listen I don't
want to tell my story out no wasn't that
let's do it let's do it I came it's in
1978 and I remember I lend it to the JFK
Pan Am is this an alien and am there
away our business yeah
I'm Spanish yeah and I was working on
quince Bulevar I know sorry go ahead
right you tell them not advice for a
swine said Alex Anders would use a
department store for some of the old are
you
right my actual official name is
Alexander it what it will massage or
whatever and I looked and I was was my
cousin who was already a year in this
country right and we walked Wyatt and
the whole family was together and I
looked and I said you know someday I'm
going to have that and she looked at me
and she you know like come on
and not exactly the Wine Library is very
similar to that
yeah so it said you know you have to
have but of course he got bigger dream
well that's the way it's a puzzling one
absolutely do on jets that's real I'm
not looking for a lot couple of points
there you want to complete justice all
right let's keep going
Angie asks successful leaders say -
you're the some of the five people you
spend the most time with how do you
level up your file this is interesting
question this is something I've spent a
lot of time trying to figure out do I am
I willing to surround myself with people
that are better than me uh I know it's
windy d-roc relax we're outside um I
know um you know a lot of a lot of times
have I wondered am i surrounded myself
with people that are not you know I'm
very nurturing you know I like having a
lot of people around me I like building
up people
you got true yeah I like it very true he
listened not because he's my son and
again I don't want to sit and bragging
in front of him he's extremely extremely
special kid if I knew what I'm going to
get I would go is the true story by the
way his mother then before we got
married she said one of these things she
wants to have five kids
and of course being younger so they had
no problem but my parents were married
at 20 right we were young and you know
the time went on and you know I got
scared about the education to be able to
pay the kids should not have long such a
nonsense they should all have loans I
would have paid it off easy bright so I
mean here he's definitely and again I'm
not going to sit and brag about you but
I think I might have you on the show
more often I'm feeling nice physics you
know what I'd be a better honest with
you maybe somebody out there who's going
to stumble on this video whatever his
DNA should be below there I'm very
serious not because we had four points
that helps but I mean he is extremely
extremely special in many ways and and
and you know I don't know Barack Obama
doesn't invite him to the White House
please I'm is nice and
you know just because I get it you know
and you know um as a father they're
proud in the business we had a lot of
discreet with this is a grill out that
ever forgot them thing but the end of
the day we bounce off each other sinks
and I don't think Gary ever mentions
that because he's a very competitive guy
but a lot of good ideas and I don't want
to put myself somewhere but a lot of
them beginning could was a wine library
it's came driving an hour each way I
wrote and I wrote a million morning I
wrote about dad you know what I miss
this so much I miss it so much and and I
understand listen he got things going on
and but that part I I always miss
because it's it's what's very special I
you know even even today when the family
gets together it's even my daughter's
birthday was a couple days ago
you know she turned what thirty-six
right
sorry lesser here no but you know even
her friends saw the dynamic of our
family it's and I have to give it to mom
mom built a very strong foundation who
grew up without a mother you know she
was at age five she lost her mother and
but she's a very special person who
built this family and you know I work
and she was building the family and it's
a great combination and it's a you know
I mean I'm very proud what this family
were able to accomplish and what Gary
and Agee I mean you know special kids
definitely spent all of them and I I see
grandchildren the Oliver and
you know the other he is interceding a
lot of Olives with yeah I mean balancer
and he wants to call himself our and
it's really real special real special
thanks that I'm no idea nd what the
question was but what was again some of
the five people you spend the most time
right yeah I mean I think that yeah I
think I think I have I definitely over
the last five to seven years surround
myself with higher caliber characters I
think it's a it's a commitment I think
but on the flip side I'm very
comfortable in in bringing value to the
people that maybe aren't better than me
I think giving back is massively
important I think it it's it there's a
level of karma and I think as long as
you're focused on surrounding yourself
with five people that can bring your
level up
III think the real answer is it's about
ten right I think it's about creating a
scenario where you have five people that
are leveling you up and I think it's
around about surrounding yourself with
five people that you level up and I
think I think I get tremendous enjoyment
on leveling up the five people around me
Chris asks I got a question for you how
bad you wish Tom Brady was your
quarterback this is a good the question
is how bad do I want Tom Brady to be my
quarterback you go I'll take him I mean
look Brett Favre was probably the plat
one of the five players I disliked the
most in the NFL but I've said it before
in the show the second that a player
takes on di logo they're all about right
Metro right Wayne Gretzky we didn't like
I like what my dad's a devil's fan of a
Rangers fan but um I think uh i he's get
a little I think his own open feel right
he's a little listen I would I would cut
my I'm gonna say this I would cut my
entire right arm on I would live like
blue since to come I would tuck cut
might I would cut brain I would cut my
entire right a left arm off for Aaron
Rodgers because I think we'd win the
Superbowl
Rogers the best quote by Andrew Luck I
would cut my entire left arm off for
Andrew Luck I'm going Indianapolis for
week two other than marina Tim Reno's
finished what thank God those were tough
year the Jets have really struggled I
mean we had damn Reno Jim Kelly and Tom
Brady we've had basically all three
other teams in our divisions would eat
junk show little AJ AJ is very upset
he's never won a championship and woody
she AG's never won a championship and
Slavonia AJ's 28 all right we get over
here he's flat he's dead
it is 28 he's never won a championship
because my my baseball team in hockey
team one before he was old enough to
enjoy it so he's a Nixon Jets panic AJ
would you cut your left arm off for air
Andrew Luck more AJ says no more I would
you wouldn't either right I would know I
cut my left pinkie off for short that
would you cut your left pinky up I would
I would a hundred percent what is it
what is named Carter kisser jpp yeah
John's right yeah because he's what's
going on the losses he losses in the
next finger all right let's go mom
that's it move on last question the roll
AJ's call for time we got a wrap of the
show we're going we got a spinner with
the family okay dad that's it that's it
that dad as my special guest you get to
ask the question of the day any question
you want please don't make it political
like you did a while ivory you know what
I have to say something that's not a
question
no but I want to say it and you were
young again
diamonds eschatos like I said special
kid runs the Soviet Union fell apart oh
it's a good one
how old you were 91
ah right oh yeah I was it was nice yeah
I was 15 6 I was 15 I think he walked
into the room you know that was a big
day for our family because you know we
were born and and he said the worst
thing would happen
and I look at him I was like what I'm
admitting I'm not as smart as my son but
he still had my dream a Santa she said
that's the worst thing I said why he
said it's called the unbalance in the
world meaning - superpower countries
everything was equal and you know what
years later I said she was absolutely
right it could have all all the
craziness what's going on today the
world because it's seven dollars if we
still have so detuning here hold war
basically in America here all this
[ __ ] was roses all right calm down
calm down no politics no politics
nothing would happen nobody would throw
bomb things would happen things are
absolutely not you please is that
supposed to be a question that aging
girl so what is the question well you're
supposed to ask a question I do yeah and
then people answer on it then people
answer maybe like a Jets thing a wine
thing maybe favorite wine maybe keep
chill little chill not geopolitical
intensity who's more [ __ ] matic my
song toward me Jesus they're gonna love
you for this episode you're gonna get
more votes than you deserve you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
you